has it been so much fun getting all
dressed up and gussied up for stuff like
this since I was a little girl I have
always loved that and especially on a
Sunday afternoon come on now that's what
everybody does you're bringing some
sunshine on a gloomy day thank you very
much so did you have so much fun at the
Golden Globes I had a great time sad to
say I was so close to Lisa Marie and now
she's gone you know it just proves life
is short love the people you love and
love on them
that was a pretty heartbreaking news to
received two days after seeing her right
yes it was
um you know tonight you know Abba
Elementary's continuing its amazing run
and getting all this love but what does
it mean to get recognized by the critics
because sometimes they're a tough
audience it's so funny I always remember
this critics have critics so you know
one never knows I'm just very happy that
the critics Association chose Abbott
Elementary as one of the best of the
best and I'm very thankful you must be
so thankful to have this cast this
family with you too because I was
looking at all the tables at the Globes
thinking if there was one I want to be
at it's the Abbott Elementary crew that
is the truth you know you can't lie to
the camera when people say we all look
so happy we all look like we really like
each other remember you cannot lie to
the camera because we do love each other
Abbott was renewed for a third season
already that must be a good feeling you
know something there's nothing like
believing you will have 10 episodes 10
seasons of a show and you get to the
third because you know what God is good
good let's get that syndication next
okay that's why I've got to get to the
five years baby 100 episodes yeah I have
faith I have faith have fun in there
tonight thank you very much
[Music]